am Wochenende wurde der Bahnverkehr in
Norddeutschland durch gezielte Sabotage
lärmgelegt und auch wenn der oder die
Täter noch nicht feststehen es wurde
wohl jedem schlagartig klar wie
verletzlich sie wir sind Anschläge auf
kritische Infrastruktur sind Teil von
hybrider Kriegsführung und werden im
Krieg auch gegen die Ukraine von
Russland eingesetzt und auch die
pipelines-nordstream 1 und 2 in der
Ostsee wurden gezielt zerstört was wenn
es beim nächsten Mal einen Internet
Unterseekabel trifft werden wir auf
diese Weise ganz anders in den Krieg
gegen die Ukraine hineingezogen
kritische Infrastruktur im Visier was
stärkt unsere Abwehr unser Thema in der
phoenix-runde
Phoenix Runde
guten Abend ich begrüße ganz herzlich
aus Berlin darf in meine Gäste
vorstellen ich begrüße Markus Keup er
ist Dozent für militärökonomie an der
Militärakademie der ETH Zürich herzlich
willkommen Professor Daniela schwarzer
Politikwissenschaftlerin
exekutivdirektorin für Europa und
Eurasien der open society Foundation und
zurzeit Professorin an der Herbert
Kennedy School guten Abend herzlich
willkommen Johannes rundfeld Gründer der
AG kritis das ist die
Arbeitsgemeinschaft kritische
Infrastrukturen und dahinter verbergen
sich Fachleute die mit der
IT-Sicherheit von Energieversorgung
Transport und Verwaltung zu tun haben
und herzlich willkommen Georg Mascolo
Publizist er leitete zuletzt die
Recherche Kooperation von NDR WDR und
Süddeutscher Zeitung Herr mask reden wir
mal zuerst über diese Sabotage jetzt hat
die
Generalbundesanwaltschaft die
Ermittlungen aufgenommen die halt eben
diesen Sabotageakt betreffen wie
bewerten sie das sie hat es ja in beiden
Fällen getan zunächst was die Pipeline
angeht jetzt auch den Bahn für all
Verfassungs manche Sabotage da müssen
selbst Juristen nachschauen wann das
eigentlich das letzte Mal der Fall
gewesen ist und es zeigt was in dieser
Sache jedenfalls vermutet wird nämlich
dass es sich hier nicht um normale
Sachbeschädigungen handelt sondern dass
es sich mit Tätern zu tun haben zu tun
haben die diese Infrastruktur angreifen
weil sie den Bestand der Republik die
Festigkeit der Republik
herausfordernd prüfen wollen so das ist
der Verdacht der hier in dieser Sache im
Raum ist und die Ernsthaftigkeit sieht
man im Fall dieser Ermittlung aber es
gibt viele Menschen denken sofort auch
das muss doch dann aus dem Kreml kommen
gibt es dafür Hinweise na gut im Fall
der Pipeline können wir glaube ich
ziemlich sicher sagen dass das was man
sich ansonsten vorstellen kann das ist
auch andere Form von Extremismus
Terrorismus sein kann dass das glaube
ich bei einer Pipeline auf dem
Meeresgrund ganz weitgehend
ausgeschlossen ist dafür braucht man
schon staatliche Ressourcen im Fall der
Bahn wäre ich nun vorsichtiger
wer solche Anschläge haben wir auch in
der Vergangenheit gesehen der kann das
täterspektrum von bis reichen wir wissen
es noch nicht und in dem Fall würde ich
dann auch nicht spekulieren wollen
herumwelt ganz ab unabhängig vom
möglichen Täter die Tatsache dass man
zwei Kabel durchschneiden muss und damit
sozusagen den gesamten Zugverkehr in
Norddeutschland für mehrere Stunden lahm
legt das zeigt ja schon klar dass wir
sehr verletzlich sind sind wir das
wirklich ja natürlich wir sind in diesem
Bereich sehr verletzlich Infrastruktur
egal welche Netze ob ein Bahnnetz ein
Kabelnetz ein Glasfasernetz oder ein
Stromnetz lässt sich in der Fläche des
Landes so gut wie nicht schützen was wir
tun können ist immer so bauen dass sie
resilient ist wenn sie redundant ist
also das wäre an einer Stelle etwas
auf Deutsch
also Residenz heißt wenn einem der
montageakt oder ein natürlicher Vorfall
ein Bagger einen Unfall in einem Baum
eine Leitung zerstört dann sollten wir
das Netz das System so planen
der ausfalllokal begrenzt und
kurzfristig ist das können wir machen
was wir nicht machen können ist 15.000
km Glas Wasser schützen aber was würden
Sie jetzt für eine schlussverordnung
ziehen eben aus diesem Fall oder haben
wir das zu lange haben wir da gar nicht
richtig hingeguckt ich denke die Bahn
muss ihre Netze grundsätzlich überdenken
überlegen ob sie genügend Fasern verlegt
haben ob sie genug Rückfall Ebenen haben
und insbesondere in diesem Fall kann man
sagen die Rückfall Ebene dann das
normale Handynetz zu benutzen was zurück
in der Bahn ist hat ja nicht
funktioniert die Frage müssen wir uns
stellen warum er das nicht funktioniert
und vielleicht brauchen wir auch eine
weitere Rückfall Ebene bei der Bahn okay
also da könnte man noch was tun reden
wir gleich nochmal weiter rüber Herr
Kollege wir wissen nicht wer die Täter
sind aber bei den Anschlägen auf die
Pipeline hat ja maskulär schon auch
deutlich gemacht dass das sehr wohl von
staatlicher Seite gewesen sein kann der
macht uns ja deutlich wie wie sehr wir
ja getroffen werden können welche
Hinweise haben Sie dass das Teile dass
das Teil einer hybriden Kriegsführung
ist ja so nach russischer Doktrin ist
das Thema Hybride Kriegführung nicht
gerade neu man hat im Westen so 2013 das
als gerasimov Doktrin benannt nach dem
Chef des russischen Generalstabs Valerie
gerade
es ist nicht ungewöhnlich für die
russische Taktik auch Mittel einzusetzen
die jenseits der eigentlichen
militärischen Kampfführung liegen wenn
sie jetzt zum Beispiel konkret Nord
Stream 2 anschauen also wenn wir mal
annehmen es waren die Russen das sehen
Sie das eigentlich ganz gut weil
nordstring 2 besteht aus zwei Strängen
und nur einer von denen ist getroffen
worden der andere ist nach wie vor
theoretisch aktiv das heißt sie könnten
Gas da durchschicken und wunderbar was
passiert Putin bietet an ja ich könnte
euch schon Gas liefern durch diesen
einen noch bestehenden Strang sie haben
massive Aktivitäten der Russen im
cyberraum schon vor der sogenannten
Annexion der Krim gehabt es hat sich
seither natürlich intensiviert also ich
denke es ist nicht wirklich neu das
Russland diese Politik verfolgt was neu
ist ist das ein Großteil der Menschen
vor allem auch in Deutschland zum ersten
Mal merkt das ist so ist also dass wir
komplexen bedrohungsvektor entgegen
stehen und eigentlich nicht wirklich
darauf vorbereitet sind und darauf muss
man jetzt Antworten finden sie haben es
ja völlig richtig gesagt Redundanz von
Netzen auch die neu Strukturierung den
Neubau von Netzen überdenken ich sehe es
ähnlich wie Sie also ein vollständiger
Schutz der Infrastruktur ist schon aus
Kostengründen gar nicht möglich sondern
man muss die Strukturen so bauen dass
man im Prinzip sagen kann ja Schlag
ruhig drauf die Struktur ist so
resilient dass sie sich von selber neu
verdratet von selber neu vernetzt oder
die Kapazität einfach umleitet ja man
hat dann lokal irgendwo ein Leck aber im
Gesamtsystem passiert nichts und ich
denke das das ist eigentlich eine gute
Strategie gegen Hybride Kriegsführung
aber dafür muss man dann auch
investieren und entsprechend die Netze
analysieren auch topologisch sich
angucken wie funktionieren die und dann
vielleicht auch neu bauen okay das ist
das was uns betrifft Frau Schwarz aber
wenn wir jetzt mal auch auf die Ukraine
schauen überhaupt die Tatsache wie
Russland mit hybrider Ausführung umgeht
bei welcher Erkenntnisse haben sie da
also Russland führt seit Jahren
eigentlich hybridenkrieg in Europa und
worüber wir am meisten geredet haben in
den vergangenen Monaten ist natürlich
der intensivierte Krieg in der Ukraine
seit 24 Februar aber gleichzeitig
destabilisiert Russland über die Grenzen
der Ukraine hinaus und ich finde es sehr
interessant dass wir in was bei uns
passiert über die vergangenen Jahre es
war zur Kenntnis genommen haben aber
immer wieder gedacht haben naja das war
jetzt einmalig nenne ein Beispiel die
vorletzte Präsidentschaftswahl in
Frankreich da wurde kurz bevor die
Kampagne enden musste das E-Mail-Konto
von dem kampagnenteam von macron gehackt
und es wurden echte E-Mails und Fake
News vermischt
veröffentlicht und da konnte er dann gar
nichts mehr entgegenhalten und damals
hat man das nach einiger Zeit Russland
attribuiert ebenso wie die Intervention
im amerikanischen Wahlkampf und das Ding
geht man danach aber dann vergisst man
das tendenziell auch immer wieder und
was wir jetzt erleben ist glaube ich
schon ein ein neuer Moment eben weil
diese beiden Vorfälle uns jetzt hier in
Deutschland so direkt und so massiv
betreffen der Ausfall der Deutschen Bahn
und der andere nicht wissen ob wissen
wir nicht wissen aber da sehen wir
plötzlich ich finde die Debatte hat sich
verändert und das kann jetzt noch nicht
attribuiert werden vielleicht nie aber
dieses Gefühl der Verletzlichkeit
die Angst natürlich auch vor dem
konventionellen Krieg die ist jetzt da
und Russland nutzt das aus dieses
angstmoment weil es letztendlich
natürlich um echten Schaden geht wenn
kritische Infrastruktur zerstört wird
aber Teil der hybriden Kriegsführung ist
auch die gesellschaftliche
Destabilisierung und da wird natürlich
das Thema ja Desinformation sehr stark
eingesetzt es wird gezielt polarisiert
es wird gezielt Protest finanziert also
da ist auch außerhalb der Ukraine schon
sehr sehr viel los in Europa man merkt
das ja bei vielen Leuten die sich jetzt
eben dann Gedanken machen gerade seit
diesem Wochenende was wäre denn dann die
richtige Antwort auf Russland ja ich
denke es kommt gar nicht so sehr darauf
an ob man Russland jemals wirklich
juristisch oder eindeutig als Schuldigen
identifizieren kann weil die
Schlussfolgerung bleibt dieselbe die
destabilisierungswirkung ist eigentlich
das gefährliche sowohl für unsere
technischen Infrastrukturen wie auch für
unsere Gesellschaft das heißt die
Probleme die sich jetzt stellen aufgrund
des angriffskriegs in der Ukraine sind
im Prinzip die gleichen die sie stellen
würden bei internen Terrorismus bei
interner Sabotage und die
Schlussfolgerung ist die gleiche wir
müssen unsere Netze technisch so bauen
dass sie resilient werden und wir müssen
genauso unsere Gesellschaft in einer
gewissen Weise sensibilisieren oder wenn
Sie wollen Härten dass sie eben sich
bewusst ist wir leben nicht mehr in
irgendwelchen normalen friedlichen
Zeiten sondern wir haben es hier mit
einem sehr sehr schlau und und
vielfältig operierenden Gegner zu tun
der sich auch ganz bewusst der
Desinformation bedient das ist der
älteren Generation vielleicht noch
bewusst aus dem Kalten Krieg wo man wo
man solche Szenarien einfach im
täglichen Leben hatte ich denke wir sind
heute mit mit unserer heutigen
Gesellschaft auf das nicht mehr
vorbereitet und müssen es zu einem
gewissen Teil neu vorbereitet werden wir
müssen es neu erlernen denke ich mit mit
diesem bedrohungsvektor umzugehen ja
hierin liegt das einfach jetzt viel
präsenter also wir sind ja groß geworden
also ich bin in einer Generation groß
geworden wo Frieden in unserem Land war
klar es gab den Kalten Krieg aber wir
hatten das Gefühl wir sind irgendwie
geschützt und nach Ende des Kalten
Krieges umso mehr und plötzlich müssen
wir sehen dass der Staat nicht schützen
kann er kann die Voraussetzung schaffen
das Resilienz besteht das heißt im Falle
einer einer Attacke durch Hybride Mittel
dass man möglichst schnell zum
Normalzustand zurückkommt aber die
Grundannahme muss sein es kann Angriffe
geben und wir sind verletzlich und das
ist gesellschaftlich eine große
Herausforderung Schutz
aber es gibt schon die Erwartungen und
ich finde auch der Anspruch dass der
Staat jedenfalls ebenso schwierigen
Zeiten sein Möglichstes dafür tut um ein
hohes Schutzniveau zu sichern das finde
ich das Ärgerliche an der Diskussion die
wir hier heute Abend zu führen haben es
gab ein Weißbuch der Bundeswehr nach dem
Einmarsch auf der Krim aus dem es
abgeleitet worden eine neue Konzeption
zivile Verteidigung alle hier am Tisch
wissen wovon ich rede und man kann im
Grunde zurückschauen so wie wir das in
den letzten Jahren so häufig haben tun
müssen und sagen müssen die Erkenntnis
ist da gewesen es gab eigentlich auch
feste Verabredung was zu geschehen ist
und schauen wir uns heute an was
geschehen ist dann ist das in vielen
Bereichen einfach zu wenig große Übungen
die vereinbart waren haben nicht
stattgefunden Verpflichtungen in der
Industrie sind nicht eingehalten worden
über die Frage wie der
Katastrophenschutz eigentlich zwischen
Bund und Ländern organisiert ist ist aus
anderem Anlass hier schon gesprochen
worden Corona die Flut oder was auch
immer das hat wir wissen dass wir in
diesem Bereich
sehr viel zu tun gehabt hätten wir haben
in diesem Land nicht nur die Bundeswehr
vernachlässigt sondern wir haben diesen
Bereich auch sträflich vernachlässigt
und deswegen ist die Vorstellung dass
wir das jetzt in weil wir weil wir weil
es keine ausreichende politische
Achtsamkeit und Energie für diesen
Bereich gegeben hat und man kann nur
hoffen dass jetzt viel schnell
nachgeholt wird aber die Vorstellung ist
zugleich dass man jetzt innerhalb von
Wochen oder Monaten nachholen kann was
jahrelang nicht passiert ist
wird nicht funktionieren das heißt wir
werden in bestimmten Bereichen
verwundbarer sein als wir es eigentlich
sein müssten
in die Kerber möchte ich auch noch mal
schlagen meine das Budget vom Bundesamt
für Bevölkerung Katastrophenhilfe BWK
ist halbiert worden mit dem letzten
Bundeshaushalt gerade dieses Bundesamt
hätte in diesem Bereich was tun müssen
und aktiv werden können das ist das eine
auf der anderen Seite die aggretis
fordert seit 2020 die Schaffung eines
cyberhilfswerks wir haben im Bereich der
Feuerwehren tolle Strukturen mit
Berufsfeuerwehr und freiwilliger
Feuerwehr entsprechend eben besonders
Bereich auch da haben wir die normalen
Gesundheitsvorsorge und die Freiwilligen
vom DRK und im Bereich vom cyberhilfe
wenn denn mal der große Vorfall kommt
der große Hackerangriff von woanders
sind wir blank da haben wir so gut wie
keine Kapazitäten mit denen wir darauf
reagieren könnten der Faktor haben wir
15 hauptamtliche Personen im Bundesamt
für Sicherheit eine Informationstechnik
BSI die dafür zuständig werden und das
ist alles was wir haben das reicht nicht
deswegen schlagen wir vor ein
cyber-hilfswerk zu gründen
möglicherweise ähnlich wie das dänische
Hilfswerk das THW kann man sicherlich
ähnlich anbinden an der Stelle
um auch für so einen Cyber Vorfall der
Kriegsführung ist gerade nett zu sein
und dann die Folgen schnell beheben zu
können vielleicht wenn ich noch eine
Lanze für die Schweiz brechen darf ich
kenne mich ja nicht so aus mit dem mit
dem deutschen Staat und aber in der
Schweiz gibt es auch eine
Mitverantwortung der zivilenbetreiber
dieser Infrastrukturen wo man also ganz
selbstbewusst sagt im natürlich tun die
Bundesämter das ihrige aber es ist auch
Aufgabe der Industrie und Aufgabe der
zivilenbetreiber sich aktiv einzubringen
und aktiv Sicherheitslösungen zu
entwickeln für die Infrastrukturen die
sie beschreiben aus einem einfachen
Grunde vieles weiß der Staat auch gar
nicht beziehungsweise kann er technisch
gar nicht beurteilen und da denke ich
müsste man viel stärker in die zivilen
militärische Zusammenarbeit hineingehen
auch in die Zivil staatliche
Zusammenarbeit dass man nicht sagt hier
ist es gibt ein sozusagen ein
bürokratenchor und das hat sich um alles
zu kümmern sondern dass man mehr an die
Front schaut an die an die eigentliche
Technik wobei wir das im Kern so auch
kennen die Verantwortung liegt in weiten
Teilen in der Industrie es hat vor
Jahren mal die Diskussionen in diesem
Land gegeben ob beispielsweise die
Bundesregierung so eine Art Kataster
der empfindsamsten stellen in diesem
Land erstellt davon hat man wie man aus
wie ich glaube aus gutem Grund abgesehen
wenn man gesagt hat was passiert
eigentlich jede in eine solche Liste man
in die falschen Hände fallen würde das
heißt an vielen Stellen ist es in
Wahrheit auch die Industrie die weiß wo
ihre sensibelsten Stellen sind und die
die Vorkehrungen zu treffen aber wenn
wir das so konstatieren das wird dazu
langsam war nicht richtig drauf reagiert
haben Geld gekürzt haben all das Frau
schwarze sind wir dann nicht massiv
Russland in diesem Feld unterlegen
also erstmal haben wir glaube ich in den
letzten Jahren gelernt dass wir ein ganz
breiten Sicherheitsbegriff brauchen und
ich stimme kann was Kolo zu es wurde
unter investiert und nicht nur in die
Bundeswehr sondern auch in diesem
Bereich und deshalb sind wir jetzt
verbundbar wir sind aber nicht nur
deshalb verwundbar weil nicht genug
investiert wurde sondern weil wir
letztendlich in einer großen Asymmetrie
Arbeiten Russland ist zu sehr brutalen
Angriffen in all diesen möglichen Formen
bereit und wir versuchen uns dagegen zu
schützen würden aber das nicht zu
unserem Instrumentarium zählen genauso
zurück zu schlagen wir haben auch kein
Interesse an dieser Konfrontation das
heißt also im Moment sind wir in einer
klaren Defensivhaltung und versuchen das
was wir bei uns schützenswert halten und
das ist ja eben nicht nur die die
materielle Infrastruktur die
cybersicherheit sondern auch die
gesellschaftliche Resilienz die ja davon
unmittelbar immer betroffen wird und das
ist das ist die große Aufgabe im Inneren
aber ja wir sind verwundbar und ich
hoffe dass im Moment sehr breit darüber
nachgedacht wird und weiß damit auch so
dass dass man eben weil es darum geht
die Gesellschaft in dieser Situation
mitzustärken nicht nur die kritische
Infrastruktur und das in einer Phase wo
wir vor allem Winter stehen der
schwierig wird ja weil wir
Energieversorgung Wirtschaftseinbruch
und so weiter alles sorgenthemen sind da
ist politische Führung wirklich auch in
ganz hohe politischer Hinsicht gefragt
zusätzlich muss natürlich investiert
werden und die Infrastruktur
resilienterinnen und die Gefahr durch
Desinformation ist ja auch ganz groß die
ist die ist groß aber sie ist auch das
ist ein ein täglich eine tägliche
Auseinandersetzung Desinformation ist
täglich bei uns im Internet unterwegs
und natürlich auch in anderen Staaten
die aus russischer Sicht noch leichter
zu destabilisieren sind Anrainerstaaten
der der Ukraine also da sind wirklich
dass das findet täglich statt also es
ist keine Bedrohung die die irgendwo in
der Zukunft liegt das ist so und das ist
die waren gerade in moldauern ich war
gerade in der Republik Moldau und da
sieht man ein kleines Land Nachbarland
der Ukraine dreieinhalb Millionen
Einwohnern etwa von der Energie
Erkrankung noch sehr stark von
Strom aus der Ukraine von Gas aus
Russland abhängig jetzt wurden in den
letzten Monaten sehr viel getan um über
Rumänien Alternativen aufzubauen aber
dieses Land spürt täglich was es heißt
hybrider Kriegsführung ausgesetzt zu
werden über Druck durch die
Gaslieferungen jetzt die Zerstörung von
Infrastruktur in der Ukraine senkt die
Möglichkeit Strom aus der Ukraine in das
Land zu importieren es gibt
Desinformationskampagnen noch und nöcher
bezahlte Demonstrationen direkt vor dem
Amtssitz der Präsidentin mit
russischsprachigen transparenten damit
die Videobilder auch direkt dann für
russische Propaganda benutzt werden
können also da sehen sie wirklich das
ganze Spektrum und die große Sorge ist
da sobald die Energieversorgung noch
schwieriger wird der Preis noch weiter
steigt das dann eben die
gesellschaftliche Stabilität wirklich
leidet und es dann sehr sehr schwierig
ist in so einer Situation noch politisch
zu führen
vermissen Sie hier in Deutschland ja
noch eine bestimmte Ansprache der
politischen Führung die klar macht wie
Ernstes auch für uns ist
wenn wir das sollen sie sagten gerade
politische Führung ist da wichtig
da bin ich nicht sicher ob ich sie ob
ich die Ansprache vermisse oder ob ich
mir nicht eher eine Ernsthaftigkeit bei
der Lösung der anstehenden Probleme
wünschen würde wobei ich nur wiederholen
kann das wird jetzt schnell nicht
passieren können
aber ich will nur einmal daran erinnern
warum die Aufregung im Moment so groß
ist und ich glaube auch berechtigt so
groß ist wir wussten ja alle schon dass
wir ohnehin aufgrund der
Energieknappheit in einen schwierigen
Winter gehen würden aber natürlich
hießen alle Prognosen immer kommen wir
mit den Vorkehrungen die wir getroffen
haben Katar Norwegen mit allen Versuchen
auch innerhalb der Europäischen Union
kommen wir durch diesen Winter
wenn man jetzt allerdings befürchten
muss dass auf dieses Problem noch das
Problem von gezielter Sabotage oder
störakten dazu kommt dann potenziert
sich natürlich die Frage wie dieser
Winter wird oder werden könnte auf eine
Art und Weise die sich auch schlicht
jeder Vorhersage entzieht das schafft
diese große
Verunsicherung jetzt dass wir bei beiden
Fällen letztlich nicht genau wissen wo
es hergekommen ist aber dass wir auch
nicht sagen können ob das der Auftakt zu
etwas ist es gibt allerdings ein Land
auf der Erde um das zu sagen dass fast
einmal den vollen Zyklus hat durchlaufen
müssen wozu Russland in der Lage ist und
zwar nicht nur militärisch sondern auch
im Bereich Cyber lange vorher dass die
Ukraine gewesen wo mehr oder weniger mit
allen Störmaßnahmen einschließlich
übrigens starken Angriffen auf das
Stromnetz und die Energieversorgung
Russland im Grunde auch sein gesamtes
Instrumentarium des cyberkrieges einmal
ausprobiert hat und es ist Furch was
würde das für die Energieversorgung
bedeuten herumfällt wenn wir jetzt wir
haben alle Angst dass es nicht reicht
dass wir das die gaspeicher nicht genug
gefüllt sind all das aber wenn man jetzt
Energieversorgung kritische
Infrastruktur was könnte da passieren
wir haben ja bereits erste Auswirkungen
man muss zu sagen quasaray Schäden
bereits erlebt zu Beginn des Konflikts
im Frühjahr hat Russland mit
cybermitteln ein
Satellitenkommunikationssystem
angegriffen mit dem auch ukrainische
Truppen kommuniziert haben der Angriff
erfolgte auf diese Weise dass die Modems
die im Feld verteilt sind dass die ein
Software Update bekommen haben dass
falsch war also bewusst schädlich und
diese Modems deaktiviert hat 30.000
dieser Geräte waren betroffen und bei
uns hat sich das ausgewirkt dass
5800 Windkraftanlagen nicht mehr
fernwartbar waren also es gab keinen
Zugriff vom Leitstand mehr auf diese
Windkraftanlagen einerseits andererseits
wurden auch die Satellit
Navigationsgeräte in den sogenannten
Einsatzleitwagen der deutschen
Feuerwehren zerstört oder gestört und
mussten ausgetauscht werden vor
gerichtlich also die
cyberbestrebungen von Russland haben
bereits auf deutsche stromauswirkungen
gehabt vor diesem Hintergrund
kann ich nur deutlich sagen wir dürfen
im cyberraum nicht scharf schießen wir
müssen uns verteidigen wir brauchen
Burgen keine Kanonen wir müssen die
IT-Sicherheit stärken und wir müssen
Sicherheitslücken sofern sie bekannt
werden Sie sofort schließen die
Betreiberinnen in diesem Bereich noch
mehr in der Haftung nehmen und
verantwortlich machen wenn sie bei der
IT-Sicherheit [ __ ] und nur so
kommen wir aus diesem Ding raus
stattdessen haben wir aber eine
Bundesregierung die ist für angemessen
hält Sicherheitslücken zurückzubehalten
um diese
auszunutzen dann dürfen wir nicht
akzeptieren das Gesellschaft wir
brauchen die Defensive
cybersicherheitsstrategie weil wir schon
gesehen haben wer offensiv room cybert
der richtig emoklateralschäden an und
diese sind wir uns nicht tragbar wie
schön dass diese Forderung von jemand
wie ihnen kommt ich freue mich sehr ich
denke auch vielleicht bei aller bei
allem Pessimismus zu dem man ja in
Deutschland immer so so schön Neid nicht
die Welt geht unter und wir werden alle
sterben naja gut man muss auch sehen
dass Putin sicherlich einige Fehler
gemacht hat in dieser Politiker hat
beispielsweise meiner Ansicht nach die
gaskarte viel zu früh gespielt überlegen
Sie mal er hätte sie fünf Jahre später
gespielt also mit der Anbindung
nordstring 2 voll entwickelt
also ich denke schon dass man jetzt auch
nicht nein aber die Lage ist auch nicht
so schlimm wie viele sie darstellen also
wenn sie jetzt zum Beispiel sagen
russland hat erhebliche cybermittel
eingesetzt in der Ukraine ja und das ist
zum Beispiel der Grund warum die Ukraine
auf starlink gewechselt hat also dieses
System das er von von Elon Musk
betrieben wird ich möchte jetzt keine
Werbung hier für diesen Mann machen aber
einfach um um genau dieses Problem zu
umgehen ja nämlich um die lokalen
cybermittel nicht versuchen irgendwie
herum zu operieren sondern einfach zu
sagen wir gehen auf eine andere Art von
Technologien von Architektur die gar
nicht mehr zugänglich ist der russischen
angriffsführung wenn Sie jetzt die
deutsche Gasversorgung im Winter
angucken ja natürlich wird es schlimm
aber trotzdem also mit mit etwa 20%
Einsparungen und und einem einigermaßen
milden Herbst wird man durch den Winter
kommen natürlich dauert das jetzt einige
Jahre die Energieinfrastrukturen
umzubauen in Europa bzw in Eurasien es
ist aber nicht so dass man hilflos
diesen Dingen gegenüber steht im
Gegenteil ist gerade das meiner Ansicht
nach des russische narrativ oder oder
auch vielleicht ein Teil der russischen
Desinformation ist nämlich so
darzustellen dass schreckliche
übermächtige russland hat uns alle in
der Hand wir sind so furchtbar abhängig
und können nicht gegen Russland hilft
nur eine Politik der Stärke und wenn er
unfällt sagt ja ganz klar wir müssen
defensiv bleiben ist das auch ihre
Meinung oder kann man auf eine andere
Art auch dieser dieser cyberdrohung oder
dem diesen Gefahren irgendwie
entgegentreten denke nicht dass man das
jetzt vergleichen kann also herunfällt
hat sich als speziell auf die Cyber
Strate angezogen hast als ich gesagt
habe gegen Russland hilft eine Politik
der Stärke meinte ich die Verhandlung
mit bzw die nicht Verhandlung mit
russischen Entscheidungsträgern ich
meine konkret folgendes solange Putin
noch das Gefühl hat man hört ihn zu man
spricht mit ihm man versucht ihn
anzurufen so lange hatte natürlich auch
den Eindruck er hat noch man im Freiraum
er kann auch reden mit den Leuten und
vor allem er kann sie unter Druck setzen
Angst bekommt er wirklich erst wenn
Stille herrscht wenn niemand mehr mit
ihm redet wenn man eine Politik der
Stärke so fährt dass man sagt wir
brauchen dich nicht und wir haben auch
keine Angst vor deinen sogenannten
Aktionen erst dann wird sich
wahrscheinlich irgendetwas ändern aber
sie sprechen ja in wichtigen Punkt an
danke dafür ich will daran erinnern dass
bei dem letzten physischen treffen ist
es zwischen Joe Biden und Wladimir Putin
gegeben hat im Mai in Genf zum ersten
Mal im Gespräch zwischen zwei
Großmächten viel weniger um nukleare
Fragen gegangen ist sondern um
cyberfragen weil jedenfalls die
US-Regierung diese als inzwischen so
wichtig erachtet und es gibt eine klare
amerikanische
die heißt
wenn wir feststellen können dass es zu
großen Cyberangriffen auf uns kommt von
russischer Seite dann werden wir auf
eine ähnliche Art und Weise
zurückschlagen und ich würde jedenfalls
bis zum Beweis des Gegenteil sagen ist
die Amerikaner die Erfinder des
Internets sind und es wahrscheinlich
keine gute Idee ist sich mit ihnen in
diesem Bereich anzulegen also es heißt
in dem Moment wo solche Cyberangriffe
von russischer Seite zunehmen
nachweisbar sind ist die Vorstellung des
der Westen und westliche Staaten all das
wenn er sie selber zum Opfer würden
akzeptieren würden zucken und und nicht
überlegen würden in welchem Maße Sie
möglicherweise in gleicher Art und Weise
reagieren könnten
halte ich für unwahrscheinlich sondern
dann würden wir nach meiner Überzeugung
auch eine echte Eskalation im zauberraum
Erleben in einer offenen
Auseinandersetzung okay könnten sie sich
das auch vorstellen Frau Phase sie sind
zurzeit lehren sie in haarwirt und
Präsident beiden hat ja jetzt hat sich
ja zum zweiten Mal innerhalb von wenigen
Tagen an Putin gewandt und hat ja so ein
Gespräch am Rande des G20 betreffens
jetzt nicht mehr ausgeschlossen da
geht's eigentlich um was anderes geht um
der Inhaftierte basketballspielerin aber
das ist ja die Frage ob es ob es da
vielleicht so ein ob das sozusagen ein
Stück der Tür ist die geöffnet wird ich
finde es richtig mit Wladimir Putin zu
sprechen ich würde ihnen nicht zustimmen
dass das man dadurch Stärke zeigt dass
man nicht miteinander redet sondern ich
denke man muss miteinander reden und
gleichzeitig zeigen dass man nicht
erpressbar ist und dass man die Stärke
hat auch diesen Angriffen etwas
entgegenzusetzen nämlich die eigene
Resilienz und ganz gute nachträglich ist
dann falsch dass der ukrainische
Präsident selenski gesagt hat er will
auf keinen Fall mit Putin sprechen das
kann ich verstehen dass in der je die
akuten Phase des Krieges wo Russland
auch noch mal sehr deutlich eskaliert
hat er das nicht macht und das ist
vielleicht auch tatsächlich jetzt nicht
das was eine gute Idee ist sie fragten
ja nach Joe beide und da würde ich sagen
wenn es da noch ein Draht gibt den man
nutzen kann dann sollte man ihn nutzen
die Frage ist aber tatsächlich und da
sollten wir uns wenig Illusionen machen
ob Wladimir Putin im Moment Interesse
hat über ein Waffenstillstand oder gar
kein Ende des Krieges zu verhandeln im
Moment zeigt alles dagegen trotzdem
würde ich sagen wie sie sagen wird falls
eine Tür aufgeht lieber miteinander
sprechen aber sehr sehr klar auch die
Position darlegen und das haben die USA
in den letzten Wochen wiederholt sehr
deutlich getan und und letztendlich ein
sehr klar aufgezeigt wie sie antworten
würden da ist zum einen das Thema Cyber
aber das natürlich auch das Thema
nukleare Eskalation wo der Preis für
Wladimir Putin von den Amerikanern klar
skizziert wurde und das soll natürlich
abschreckend wirken das ist im Moment
die Antwort auf die zunehmende
Eskalation der Russen im konventionellen
und hybridenbereich wenn sie mir
erlauben
die Frage ist natürlich schon worüber
sie dann reden möchten
also wenn sie an Golda Meyer denken dir
dieses wunderbare Zitat gebracht wird es
ist schwer mit einem Gegner zu
diskutieren die sie töten möchte worüber
sprechen Sie ich bin der Ansicht
zunächst einmal müssten sich die
russischen Truppen vollständig aus der
Ukraine zurückziehen bevor sie überhaupt
anfangen miteinander zu sprechen weil
sonst nimm Putin sich schlichtweg nicht
ernst warum sollten Sie die russische
Aggression dadurch belohnen dass sie
nach dem Einmarsch auch noch
Gesprächsangebote machen die Logik
stellt sich meiner Ansicht nach weder
militärisch noch strategisch im
Gegenteil ich halte es ehrlich gesagt
für besser wenn man Putin signalisiert
schaue du bist im Moment dabei den Krieg
zu verlieren und den Eindruck haben wir
jetzt nach über acht Monaten nicht ganz
nicht ganz acht Monaten russischer
Operationsführung doch sehr deutlich
dass dieser Krieg für Russland
langfristig nicht durchzuhalten ist
Kiew bombardiert viele andere Städte zu
Liebe Bevölkerung was natürlich
militärisch keinen Sinn macht davon mal
abgesehen aber nur dadurch dass sie
jetzt seine Ex sowjetischen
ex-russischen Depots leer schießt heißt
das noch lange nicht dass er
militärische Wirkung erzielt im
Gegenteil das sind meine Ansicht nach
eigentlich Zeichen einer zunehmenden
Ratlosigkeit dass er zu Terrorangriffen
gegen die Zivilbevölkerung greift um sie
zu demoralisieren so wie auch Hitler
1940 britische Städte würde ich mich
ehrlich gesagt gerne auf die Seite von
Frau Schwarzer schlagen weil wir in der
Sache zwei Ziele zugleich haben wir
haben das Ziel des die Ukraine diesen
Krieg gewinnt sie muss ihnen gewinnen
und gleichzeitig haben wir das Ziel und
zwar von Beginn an dass dieser Krieg
nicht in einer großen und gegebenenfalls
sogar nuklearen Konfrontationen zwischen
dem Westen und Russland endet und
deswegen ist ehrlich gesagt jedes
Gespräch auf dem Weg das versucht dieses
zweite Risiko einzugrenzen ohne
gleichzeitig das erste Ziel nicht aus
dem Auge zu verlieren aus meiner Sicht
nie ein verschwendeter Versuch und ich
finde es ehrlich gesagt beruhigend ist
wie die US-Administration sich in diesem
Fall wirklich Schritt für Schritt ganz
genau überlegt und wie Sie vorgehen aber
es besteht auch noch ein Unterschied ob
sie sagen ich mache Putin den Preis klar
das heißt was hast du zu erwarten wenn
du nuklear eskalierst mit dem mit dem
ganz klar mit der ganz klaren
Ankündigung massiver Vergeltung oder
aber ob sie sagen sie gewöhnen sich
jetzt an eine Welt wo jemand nur nuklear
zu drohen braucht um zu erhalten was er
will aber die mit anderen Worten ich
habe
okay Gegenstand des gesprächsein nach
Putins Gedankenwelt würde das genauso
impliziert werden ich brauche nur so
lange zu drohen bis der Westen nachgeht
aus Angst es könnte ja daraus sehr
Atomkrieg entstehen sehe ich überhaupt
nicht als logische Schlussfolgerung wenn
man ein Gespräch in diesem Sinne nutzt
nämlich den Preis einer Eskalation einer
weiteren Eskalation klar zu machen dann
hat man ihn glaube ich nicht bestärkt
aber das ist für mich kein Gespräch das
ist eine Ankündigung was er zu erwarten
hat und kein Einstieg in irgendwelche
Verhandlungen das habe ich auch nicht
gesagt für mich ist ein Gespräch kein
Einstieg in eine Verhandlung die Frage
war ob die beiden sich treffen sollen
und reden sollen das heißt nicht
verhandeln da bin ich völlig bei Ihnen
jetzt ist nicht der Moment für
verhandeln und ich habe sehr deutlich
gesagt dass ich überhaupt nicht glaube
dass man mit Putin im Moment verhandeln
kann aber sprechen sollte man mit jemand
das war ihre Frage und das Problem ist
ja dann oder dadurch dass das was Gefühl
hat man muss ganz dringend fahren oder
dass viele Menschen viele muss ganz
dringend Verhandlung ist unter anderem
die Drohung der der nuklearen Eskalation
aber da würde ich gerne mal auf unser
erstes Thema noch mal zurückkommen wie
viel gefährlicher ist eigentlich
die die Zerstörung der kritischen
Infrastruktur wenn man das also von der
Drohung her herumfällt ist das was wo
man sagt da kann man wirklich auch ja
eben man kann man kann ganze Länder man
kann ganz Europa da lahmlegen das ist
eigentlich noch viel gefährlicher die
bedrohlicher nun diese Drohung ist ja
bisher nicht ausgesprochen worden und
darüber bin ich auch sehr dankbar ich
denke nicht dass man damit Europa so
zerlegen kann wie mit nuklearen Waffen
auch wenn mir ein Dekan einer
israelischen Universität da widerspricht
und behauptet dass man durch reines
cybermittel
nukleare katastrophenniveaus erreichen
kann hin natürlich davon ab was man
ausnutzt und welche Sicherheitslücken
existieren und welche dem Angreifer wie
auch immer das dann ist bekannt sind
deswegen auch hier wieder
Sicherheitslücken die uns bekannt werden
oder die wir nicht noch nicht
geschlossen haben müssen sofort
geschlossen werden und das gilt für
jeden einzelnen Computer in ganz Europa
nur das macht unsichere
okay das heißt aber man müsstet viel
mehr auch bei der Bevölkerung noch
aufklären und gucken dass jeder Einzelne
sich auch schützt bei den Betrieben bei
der in der Wirtschaft
Industriegesellschaft und natürlich auch
im Staat müssen wir aufhören veraltete
Software zu akzeptieren wir müssen
aufhören das Thema zu akzeptieren die
nicht aktualisierbar sind weil sich
jemand überlegt hat dass da jetzt ein
Stempel drauf ist also Zertifikation von
Computern
dadurch können wir dieses Risiko
effektiv mindern wenn nicht sogar gegen
Null bringen ich denke und dazu muss
eben auch der Schutz des physischen
Raumes kommen also wenn Sie zum Beispiel
denken gaskompressor Stationen
Unterwerke Transformatorenstationen oder
nehmen sie nur mal Güterbahnhöfe an
denen flüssige Treibstoffe umgeladen
werden schauen Sie mal was ist da der
Sicherheit das ist der Sicherheitslevel
also es tut mir leid in drahtzäumchen
um das Gebäude oder am Gleis das ist
ebenso diese diese gute alte friedliche
Welt nach dem Motto wir sind hier für
uns und wir machen hier unsere kleine
Eisenbahn uns passiert nichts
so können wir nicht mehr weitermachen
und wir könnten müssen uns natürlich
auch über die Grenzen hinweg natürlich
versuchen zu schützen die
nato-verteilungsminister sitzen ja
gerade zusammen groß oder gestern und
heute auch da war kritische
Infrastruktur ein Thema Frau Schwarzer
wie sehr kann man sagen oder wie sehr
passiert das schon dass man halt eben
das nicht nur als nationales Thema sieht
und Problem sieht den Schutz von
kritischen Infrastrukturen sondern dass
man das ja in einem europäischen Rahmen
und auch innerhalb der NATO sieht
passiert immer mehr aber wir haben
insgesamt das Problem dass nicht genug
für den Schutz ausgegeben wurde wieder
weder national noch im europäischen
Verbund wir haben in den letzten Jahren
in Europa Bemühungen gesehen
grenzüberschreitend Netze auszubauen das
passt zu der Idee der Integration das
passt der Idee dass das
energiebindenmarktes und so weiter aber
im Bereich Schutz ist europäisch nicht
mehr gemacht worden als jetzt wir auf
deutscher Ebene jetzt beispielhaft
konstatiert haben dass es da ein
Investitionen und Resilienz der
Strukturen fehlt was man aber sieht ist
das politisch die Einsicht gewachsen ist
auch J von Russland dass wir uns selber
schützen müssen und stärker schützen
müssen und ich möchte ein anderes
Beispiel nennen das eher mit Blick auf
China entwickelt wurde nämlich Europa
hat gemeinsam ein sogenannten
Investitionen eine sogenannte
investitionsschutzrichtlinie
verabschiedet die national umgesetzt
wurde vor zwei Jahren und die Idee dabei
ist dass man viel stärker Kontrolle
darüber hat wer in welche Bereiche
investiert oder Unternehmen aufkauft die
man als kritisch betrachten muss und da
haben wir durch die kobit-krise noch mal
eine eine ganz neue Dimension erlebt man
hat vorher vielleicht eher an den
Bereich Technologie
IT und so weiter gedacht und der
Gesundheitssektor ist jetzt viel stärker
auch mit in den Blick geraten und da hat
Europa schon etwas gemacht eben da würde
man jetzt überhaupt nicht an Hybride
Kriegsführung natürlich denken aber es
hat auch mit Schutz zu tun dass man über
kritische Industrien und vor allen
Dingen auch neuralgische Punkte in den
Lieferketten mehr Kontrolle haben möchte
und zunächst auch mal mehr Transparenz
und wissen möchte wo man eben im Zweifel
im Zweifelsfall in einem Konflikt ganz
wichtige Versorgungsgüter beispielsweise
medizinische Güter und nicht mehr unter
Kontrolle hätte und das ist also da hat
Europa einen Teil dazu beigetragen aber
letztendlich liegt die Umsetzung dann
immer noch sehr stark auch auf
nationaler Ebene also das wäre sinnvoll
für uns sehen Sie das auch sehr unfällt
dass man das so zusammen als europäisch
andenkt ja in jedem Fall müssen wir hier
in Europa zusammenhalten und dafür
sorgen dass wir uns selbst versorgen
können mit dem Nötigsten wir sind in der
globalisierten Welt wird das nicht immer
gehen und das immer Dinge geben die wir
importieren und zu kaufen müssen aber
gerade wir als Exportnation sollten da
selbstbewusst aufstehen und gucken was
wir selbst machen können weil wir
dadurch auch Unabhängigkeit bekommen die
wir sonst nicht hätten ich meine es gibt
ja auch schon solche Instrumente also
zum Beispiel die sogenannte
solidaritätsrichtlinie im Gasmarkt der
EU die ist ja jetzt schon in
freiwilliger Anwendung aber sie würde
auch im Prinzip oder zwangsweisen
Umsetzung die Staaten ermächtigen das
heißt also wenn ein Staat zu wenig hat
und der andere Staat hat ein volles
Lager dann könnte die EU-Kommission im
Prinzip sagen start a muss jetzt anstatt
B ausgleichslieferung vornehmen das ist
noch nie wirklich angewendet worden aber
ich denke es geht auch durch
Freiwilligkeit also im Gasmarkt passiert
jetzt etwas ganz
Außergewöhnliches nämlich Frankreich
liefert Gas an Deutschland erstmals in
diesem Winter vorher war es immer
umgekehrt Grund frankreich hat vier
lng-terminals das heißt hat überhaupt
kein Problem sein Gas von See zu
bekommen spanien hat übrigens sieben das
heißt also wir könnten
in Deutschland kommen sie dann
vielleicht irgendwann mal so 2026 aber
was ich meine ist eigentlich wir haben
eigentlich ein ein sehr
starken westlichen Link der also weit
ausgreift in die Weltmeere über die wir
sehr viel machen könnten im Bereich
Import richtig auch
Energieinfrastrukturen ist halt eine
Frage dieser diese Korridore auszubauen
ich würde gerne mal auf eine Sache
schauen halt inwieweit man auf der
anderen Seite ja nicht Angst verbreiten
soll und Sicherheit in der Bevölkerung
das weil das auch etwas ist was was
putinant gezielt auch gerne möchte auf
der anderen Seite natürlich dafür Sorge
tragen möchte dass die Bevölkerung
geschützt ist ja Maske wie geht man
damit um sollte wäre es gut dass jeder
jetzt weiß ich brauche einen
Notfallrucksack ich brauche das und das
im Keller und
sozusagen an mich auch in meiner
journalistischen Eigenschaft und da
lohnt es zuallererst mal daran zu
erinnern dass
man eigentlich nur bei einem ziemlich
sicher sein kann nämlich dass die
steilsten Vorhersagen fast nie eintreten
das erleben wir jetzt ja doch seit
langer Zeit ich darf daran erinnern
welche corona-szenarien gegeben und kann
irgendwie zurückkommen und in aller
Regel kommt es dann ganz so schlimm wie
man es sich ausmalt oder ausmalen könnte
dann doch nicht die Frage sollte man
eigentlich so einen kleinen notrucksack
in seinem Keller haben ein bisschen
Wasser oder so kann ich mich daran
erinnern wie der damalige Innenminister
Thomas de Maiziere als er das mal
öffentlich gesagt hat wirklich tagelang
in dieser Stadt und von praktisch allen
Medien verprügelt worden ist weil die
Panikmache vorgeworfen worden ist ich
glaube es war keine Panikmache
es ist gut und klug die Menschen darauf
hinzuweisen es muss übrigens auch nicht
unbedingt mit russischer hybrider
Kriegsführung zu tun haben das eine
Situation entstehen kann in der man
einfach mal drei Tage vier Tage oder so
zu Hause irgendwie zurechtkommen muss
und wenn man dann irgendwie eine
Notvorrat diese Art hat dann ist daran
nichts falsch das aber was uns wirklich
nach vorne bringen wird ist wenn wir
lernen diese Debatten die wir heute
Abend führen ein Stück früher zu führen
und sie dann auch mit Konsequenz
tatsächlich das worauf wir uns einigen
umzusetzen ist was Frau Schwarzer sagt
ich glaube vor drei Jahren haben wir am
Tisch gesessen und haben die
Diskussionen über Huawei geführt über
damals noch eine sehr strittige Frage
ich darf daran erinnern dass die
Kanzlerin dagegen gewesen ist das Huawei
ganz weitgehend aus den Netzen
jedenfalls im Kernbereich ausgeschlossen
werden sollten ich glaube es ist eine
richtige Entscheidung gewesen ich weiß
gar nicht wo wir heute stehen würden
wenn wir Huawei tatsächlich in den
kernnetzen bei 5g überall
dabei gehabt hätten aber wir sind mit
all diesen Diskussionen in aller Regel
spät dran später in aller Regel als wir
es sein müssten und wir sind in der
Umsetzung ein sehr schwerfälliges Land
geworden aber warum sind wir spät dran
warum sind ist das immer wenn man
irgendwie das nicht so wahrhaben will
weil man denkt es kann doch nicht so
schlimm werden es verdrängt oder was ich
denke es ist halt eine neue Lage die
eingetreten ist die man früher gar nicht
so gesehen hat also zum Beispiel die
simple Tatsache des Strom nicht
selbstverständlich ist wenn sie mal ein
paar Monate diesen Krieg also es ist ja
nicht Ferien in Südafrika Südafrika hat
ein schönes System das heißt birdgrach
also das sozusagen Strom im Ringel rein
ja jeder kriegt für zwei Stunden am Tag
Strom weil einfach das nationale Netz zu
ihnen stabil ist so was machen sie in so
einer Lage naja sie passen sich relativ
schnell an aber das Leben ist nicht
angenehm ich halte es für sinnvoller
dass wir gerade diese Diskussionen die
nun halt mal unangenehm sind ja das ist
nicht schön klar und man will das unter
Weihnachtsbaum auch nicht diskutieren ja
aber ich denke je früher und die
intensiver man diese Diskussionen führt
desto schneller verliert man auch die
Furcht vor solchen Szenarien wenn nun
eben mal der Strom drei Tage ausfällt
dann hat es vor allem ein Konsequenz in
den meisten Wohnhäusern fallen die
Wasserpumpen aus das heißt sie haben
keinen Trinkwasser aus der Leitung ja
gut dann stellen sie sich halt 50 Liter
Wasser irgendwo in den Keller und fertig
und kaufen ein paar Batterien und und
zwei Taschenlampen und dann dann geht
das schon also man muss die Dinge auch
nicht immer so überdramatisieren aber
man kann auch nicht mehr so naiv sein
wie wie von nach vor zehn Jahren ich
wollte gerne noch bei Herrn was coole
ergänzen weil ich
vorhin sagte er ja dass wir viel zu
wenig Geld ausgegeben haben und ich
glaube ein Teil der Diskussion die wir
jetzt führen müssen ist was ist uns
diese breite Sicherheit die wir
gesellschaftlich brauchen was ist die
uns wert und wir sehen jetzt im Moment
dass das anders über militärische
Ausgaben diskutiert wird und das ist
auch richtig der Kanzlei seine
Zeitenwende wenden Rede gehalten ich
glaube der nächste Punkt der kommen ist
dass wir über all das was gesagt wurde
an notwendigen Investitionen
Infrastruktur die zusätzlichen Kosten
die das bringt eben vorausschauender
diskutieren ohne Panikmache aber uns
einfach klar machen dass das wichtige
Investitionen sind um Stabilität zu
gewährleisten und deshalb denke ich hat
diese breitere gesellschaftliche
Diskussion auch diesen Zweck also nicht
panikmach überhaupt nicht sondern
langfristig
und die unklaren Zuständigkeiten
zwischen Bund und Ländern bei der
Angelegenheit dann auch gleich noch
einmal sortieren würden
mit dem bundeswehrbeschaffungsamt in
Koblenz oder sagst das ist da rieselt
das Geld rein aber es kommt unten nicht
viel Gutes raus nicht immer sage nur nur
weil man oben Geld rein wirft fällt
unten nicht militärische Leistung raus
also genau
komplett recht wir müssen die
Bevölkerung muss vorsorgen das sorgt
auch dafür dass man weniger Panik hat
wenn man weiß wo der Rucksack steht man
weiß da sind noch 10 Kilo Linsen die man
essen kann wenn der Strom ausfällt wenn
man weiß wo das die nächste Quelle ist
für Trinkwasser dann kann man der ganzen
Lage entspannter gegenüberstehen und es
gibt dafür Checklisten auch vom Staat
auch schon sehr alte Listen das BBK
veröffentlicht diese Bundesamt für
Katastrophenhilfe genau die Frage diese
Listen die sind sehr gut gepflegt und zu
ihnen ich gebe Ihnen Recht wir müssen
die Dinge langfristige angehen und
langfristig denken es reicht nicht dass
wir sagen ja in drei vier Jahren haben
wir hier 20 Millionen für irgendeine
blockchain-lösung ausgegeben und ein
tolles Leuchtturmprojekt nein wir müssen
Brot und Butter Aufgaben erledigen
vielleicht kann man hier festhalten ich
wähle Politiker die von
Leuchtturmprojekten und Schaufenster
Ideen sprechen nicht mehr ich wähle
Politiker die
Basisarbeit Brot und buttertätigkeiten
machen wollen und die Dinge in 20 Jahren
müssen sie jetzt auch Werbung machen
aber ich glaube wir müssen die
heraushaltung von den Bürger an die
Politik muss sein macht die 20 Jahre
Projekte machte 30 Jahre Projekte und
fand sie jetzt an und nicht erst
irgendwann ja und trotzdem hoffen wir
alle dass dieser Krieg irgendwie schnell
zu Ende geht jetzt haben wir den eine
andere Art der Kriegsführung auch
gesprochen aber ich würde ganz gerne
noch im plus 7 noch Fragen Herr Kolb was
denken Sie wie lange auf was müssen wir
uns einstellen jetzt wo ich auf der
einen Seite eskaliert auf der anderen
Seite die Ukraine ja doch auch stark ist
also ich denke der Krieg wird noch etwa
ein Jahr dauern bis nächsten September
wenn wir uns anschauen wie ist im Moment
die abnutzungsrate der russischen
rüstungssysteme da sind wir bei sehr
hohen Raten die langfristig für Russland
nicht durchzuhalten sind also in der
Verkauf Vision Operation waren es fünf
Panzer pro Tag wenn sie einfach ausgehen
von ungefähr 2700 einsatzfähigen Panzern
westlich der Wolga dann können Sie sich
selber ausrechnen wann Russland keine
Panzer mehr hat ungefähr im Mai 23 wenn
Sie das etwas strecken und sagen
militärisch am Ende ist und dadurch
richtig dieser Krieg beendet ganz
konventionell übrigens ohne jegliche
nuklearüberlegung wenn sie jetzt schauen
etliche der sogenannten mobilisierten
die Russland jetzt an die Front geworfen
hat in die Ukraine sind bereits gefallen
bzw in ukrainischer Kriegsgefangenschaft
das sagt ihnen sehr viel über Moral und
Einsatzfähigkeit der russischen Truppen
es ist eine Frage der Zeit nicht ob es
passiert sondern wann es passiert okay
gut dann nehmen wir das mal als
Schlusswort auch wenn es schlimmer
werden ist früher zu Ende wäre vielen
Dank Herr Mascolo Herr Coop Frau
Schwarzer herunfeld vielen dank ihnen
fürs zuschauen das war die
frühlingsrunde in dieser Woche machen
sie es gut jetzt folgt Phoenix der Tag
bis dann tschüss
[Musik]